hey guys Mary here from from
gamespot.com and I'm showing off the mix
here at e3 2015 I'm here with Nick from
co-op I being here I'm gonna show you a
pretty weird game that's pretty weird
I'm so excited for the audience to see
this this is called nog nog but it has a
silent G it's a one silent cheat the
other ones are pretty pretty good it's
pretty hard alright here we go so this
is like visually one one of the most
unique games I've ever seen and this is
a kind of like a little puzzler game it
seems really calm and yeah collected the
music is really nice and lovely I think
that's to ease you from when you get
frustrated probably a little bit yeah I
mean so it's like a puzzle adventure
game so there is sort of like a series
of motions you can go through to move to
the next level but really I mean it's
it's a series of these monster head toys
basically and each head has a little
world inside of it and the both the game
is just sort of exploring these little
heads playing with them as you play with
the toy almost and I just chilling out
with the music seeing what these things
do discovering what each head does and
how they sort of connect with each other
it's very like ambient relaxing game and
we really want to like emphasize that
with like sounds Gabe's the sort of
wonderful interactions that you have as
you play with little else which is a
knobs here in there and transition from
one head to the next yeah it's
absolutely three and I think that's like
just a huge part of this it seems like
something that's fun to explore and
enjoy and take your time in yeah more
like a I get a really big Hohokam vibe
from them just like enjoying my time
yeah and I'm not trying to actually
finish it per se or just you're
exploring and things happen yeah and
we're definitely hugely sorry but like
Holcomb and windowsill and a lot of Echo
Park games in general basically and sort
of all of us at co-op or pretty much
into like ambient dynamic audio and just
like very relaxed and gameplay compared
to like I guess a lot of the other stuff
DC 83 great so we just wanted to sort of
have a very chill kind of atmospheric
game we need a few more of them
this is kind of like David Lee's weird
like totem looks to them what was the
inspiration for these different art
designs so Sam I mean like he's a 2d
artist by by trade and we just saw his
art style like a Games community in
Montreal who's showing off his art style
and we're like we really want to make a
game with you and he just has a super
like eye catching style it's like very
strong like faces and you know strong
symmetrical geometric shapes and bold
colors and we just absolutely love the
look of the faces he was creating and we
jammed on a few different ideas and
suddenly came up with this this weird
little toy head mechanic
and yeah I mean people are it's what
catches people's eyes basically oh
absolutely I mean there's no way to
avoid that so what are you doing right
now like you're just basically exploring
this area hoping something interesting
is gonna happen or are these like
there's like menus within right well so
I mean there's there's a series of
different I guess levels basically you
call them I mean we're trying to like
pull away from traditional video game I
guess where it's kind of thing but
there's a series of different heads each
one is a different sort of theme this is
sort of a more nautical theme compared
to like the swampy bedroom theme of the
previous one and yeah it's sort of a
series of levels they're all in the end
game I'm going to be like interconnected
can you access them at any time
oh yeah we're sort of like you know
fixing or figuring out how we're gonna
like open the game up to the player but
in general it's gonna be sort of very
self-motivated self you know the
discoveries up to the player to sort of
like discover these different different
heads and explore how they connect to
each other so it's a very like
self-directed kind of game - and what in
terms of you know difficulty or do they
ramp up in any way or is this more of
just like an explorative type of it's
different exploration I mean there's no
there's not gonna be a boss level there
might be some sort of Secrets to find
later on for the really devoted players
but generally I mean we want and we've
seen kids playing the game and they seem
to really love it so we're not we're not
gonna try to make it inaccessible in any
way it just gonna be like a bunch of you
know wonderful different heads that you
explore and I'll show you like cool
different environments and they sort of
add up to like a larger world and it's
just about exploring them all together
it's really cool to look and see what's
within each of these various heads
they're all quite different and really
creative there's a lot of detail that
went into it although it has a you know
very simplistic look yeah on the offset
you'll you find little coins that you
can move around and play with yeah it's
something we were sort of
all inspired by the art style and now
we're seeing toy heads and everything
you know passed by you today like
there's a head and a hammer or sure
let's make that a head let's a bookcase
let's make that a head you know it's all
we're just seeing this stuff everywhere
and it's really sort of motivating us to
you know build this world together reach
the boundaries of where you can what you
can make a head out of be surprised
there's like a coin focused world it
looks like yeah so it's like submarine
sort of leaves a lot of like me I'm not
uncle treasurer underwater different
animals that you sort of meet down there
we're revisiting a lot of these levels
too as we're watching people play like
on the show floor here eighty-three
packs these things like that
yeah we're just sort of like seeing
where these ideas take us we have sort
of different themes in mind like level
packs that will work together some of
the oceans on the nature or urban things
like that so it's a we're sort of
exploring a whole bunch of different
different ideas how much gameplay would
you say is in here it's so far so I mean
the demo right here is pretty short it's
like the the froggy level and the
submarine level that's like about twenty
thirty minutes of gameplay ultimately
we're gonna aim for about maybe 15 20 25
heads for about two to three hours of
gameplay with obviously secrets to go
back and navigate through kind of thing
but yeah so on the show floor we've got
like about a twenty thirty minute demo
okay and if it's anything like Hohokam
sometimes you might just end up putting
it in the background because the music
is so wonderful that you can actually
just enjoy its own your own music yes
he's a buddy of ours
he's a former heavy metal musician
ramsey and like no this is like totally
ambient and lovely I feel like it might
be because I've heard his metal and it's
pretty pretty awesome but like this is
just such a wonderful soundtrack and so
chill and relaxing we've had people like
super stressed out from the show floor
come and play the game and just zone out
for like half an hour yes super
rewarding it's absolutely pleasure to
just listen to and enjoy and it's the
kind of thing where sometimes you just
leave it in the background so what are
we looking at here so this is the
submarine Celine was playing he's a
co-worker
exactly yeah exactly so he's just sort
of I mean we're all capable of
speedrunning this level obviously about
taking the time is chilling out and sort
of exploring all the different like you
know Bob's and whistles and in this
submarine and really I mean we're trying
to make it look like something you want
to reach out and touch and grab like
we're gonna be so we're gonna be
launching on PlayStation with Morpheus
support and so we wanted to sort of like
you know have these little toys hanging
there in front of you for you to like
almost feel like you want to reach out
and like play with these things
I'm Sam is totally our artist is totally
inspired by toy design and physical like
design of objects Oh looks like
something that kids would play with me
the thing is in the truth is is that
when you go to the doctor appointment
and you see all those cool little toys
for the kids that you want to play with
them yes and you're a liar if you don't
feel that way so this is a really good
way to do that discreetly in your own
home you don't take a toy away from the
child good but yeah I know you have this
now you have this and definitely like
you know we're watching kids play and
they just like touch everything they're
like the best players of the game
because they actually just play with
everything
adults tend to sort of try to puzzle it
all out beforehand but the kids are just
going crazy pulling on on every you know
button obvious which basically that's
fantastic well thank you so much Nick
for showing me nod I think it's really
exciting I'm looking forward to seeing
more of it and when is this again coming
out again it'll be 2016 we don't have a
fixed date right now but entitled for
2016 so thank you so much for showing us
that game thank you
alright so that was nog you can check
out that and other games on gamespot.com
for all your III coverage